this kind of pessimistic narrative which
we're mostly important for America is
simply inconsistence with reality
I think it's
um indicative of a wider problem at the
moment in terms of culture America is
the Metropole and the UK is basically a
colony
there's this phrase that again we borrow
from America which is this is a country
built a nation of immigrants
I mean I've read British history it's
not a nation of immigrants it's not why
do we do that
um I think the reason why we do that is
because we sort of don't want to concede
any point to the sort of anti-immigrant
conservative or far-right whatever you
want to call them but I think the best
way to do that is to do it on the basis
of Truth yeah rather than the basis of
any sort of myth making if you tell
people enough times that they are the
victims of racism they are the victims
of Oppression they are the victims of
discrimination
they will inevitably see it everywhere
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People a brilliant guest today is a
journalist and writer whose first book
first book is called this is not America
which is absolutely true this is why
you're here by the way because I keep
saying this and no one listens right
you're making this point now that's why
you're here let's talk about it but
before we do tell everybody who are you
uh to me uh what's been your journey for
Life how are you here thank you very
much for getting me on this program I've
been a long-term listener and Watcher of
the show so it's a great privilege to be
invited on
um as you said I'm a writer I'm also a
journalist I've written for various UK
Publications such as the new Statesman
the times the Sunday Times The Observer
um before that I worked as a tutor in a
in a secondary school I used to teach
English
um to kids that were struggling
um and I also did this during lockdown
as well
um so I'm familiar with online teaching
and the apparels of that
um before that I was a master student so
I studied English for undergraduate and
I did a master's as well in English and
I thought about going into Academia
um being a lecturer professor and so
forth but I grew slightly disillusioned
with Academia I found the kind of
Orthodoxy that I witnessed in Academia
very stifling very conformist and I also
grew the solution with the academic
style of writing I discovered that I
prefer more journalistic style of
writing writing that's more clearer more
Lucid more concise
um so that's that's that's why I decided
to
um do some freelance journalism on the
side whilst also being a tutor in a
secondary school after Academia I was
born in Nigeria
and I moved to the UK when I was nine
um and I guess that's that's most of my
story yeah absolutely and before we talk
about the book and I just think it's
such an important message for us to get
into now you mentioned the head the not
the heterodoxy quite the opposite the
Orthodoxy yes in Academia yes uh what
was it that you felt was stifling or
sort of locked into a particular world
view so this actually connects
um to why I decided to write the book in
the first place
um so a big part of the Orthodoxy in
Academia
um was about social and cultural issues
relating to race and identity
um so at the very start of the book I
explain why
um I decided to write the book in the
first place which is at UCL
um one of my one of my one of my alma
matters
um there was an open letter sent by the
Masters students at UCL to the English
faculty accusing the English faculty of
racism
um because there were not that many
black authors and black texts in the
syllabus but in that let's uh one thing
struck me which is that these
um UK based mostly UK based students use
the term bipok to describe the racism
experienced by British by ethic minority
British people in the UK
um and for those of you that don't know
bypoc is an acronym that stands for
black indigenous people of color
now it would make sense for um somebody
like Nick Griffin to talk about
protecting the indigenous communities of
the UK Nick Griffin by the way is a
former far-right uh yeah yeah leader
leader of the British national party
um what I found confusing is why
um a 22 year old
um activist left-wing activist
um in London would use a term like
indigenous
um Halo was quite left-wing
so so I so I was struck and I think it's
illustrative it's symptomatic of a wider
problem which is that when we think and
talk about race and racism we do it
through an American perspective
uh and what you mean is we download that
and apply it to the British yeah exactly
exactly yeah why is that why is that why
do we do that because surely we have
lived the experience
and and that means we understand yes
that things are different and the UK is
different from America so so why do we
regurgitate the narratives about
interrogating them in any shape or form
I think it's
um indicative of a wider problem
um so it's not just about race
um anyone that uses the internet
will inevitably encounter American
culture
um American culture influences the films
we watch the TV shows we watch the music
we listen to
um therefore it makes sense that I would
also influence the way we look at
Politics as well in the UK
um so I think it's not just
um a race thing I think it's symptomatic
of a wider problem which is that
um at the moment in terms of culture
America is the Metropol and the UK is
basically a colony
I mean it's a good point and also as
well lockdowns of course uh the killing
of George Floyd yes that must have had a
huge impact on the way we talk about
these subjects now yeah exactly I think
lockdown played a key role as well
because
um we were isolated and the only way
that we could interact with other people
was through the internet was through
social media so we became more dependent
upon social media to
um develop relationships to try to
understand the world basically
um and I think that's why it makes sense
why the George Floyd protests
accelerated
um the ways in which when we think about
race and racism we do it through an
American perspective I think Rogan made
this point actually the other day he
gave us a shout out and he was talking
about how the informational landscape is
changing and he said trigonometry sort
of in in that context yes but I'm
curious before we talk about how Britain
and America are different when it comes
to race which of course they are I also
feel like uh there's a lot of stuff
going on at the moment where you're just
going like we keep being
a dishonest about these issues but also
there's lots of other stuff going on so
I'll give you an example uh the BBC's
just released a thing which is something
it's called something like been here all
along or something yeah and it's
basically trying to present the picture
of like Britain from 2000 years ago
being massively populated with black
people
[Music]
and when people pointed out how
historically inaccurate this is there's
actually a quote from one of the
producers basically saying well we've
got to lie to make it work in the modern
context or something yeah and so I never
understood this like there's this phrase
that again we borrow from America which
is this is a nation of immigrants I mean
I've read British history it's not a
nation of immigrants it's not and I'm an
immigrant it doesn't make me feel better
that we lie about this yeah how why do
we do that
um I think the reason why we do that is
because we sort of don't want to concede
any point to the sort of anti-immigrant
conservative or far right whatever you
want to call them
um but I think the best way to do that
is to do it on the basis of Truth yeah
rather than the basis of any sort of
myth making because if we concede the
truth to Sinister nefarious actors
um we are actually doing a disservice to
ethnic minority people people from
immigrant Community backgrounds so I
think we should definitely base on the
truth rather than trying to
um
feather sort of respect for
um ethnic minority people on the basis
of something which
a lot of people without any kind of
ideological
um bias will know to be completely
dishonest and I was curious also what
you made of the there was a recent
incident as we said there literally a
couple of days ago where a black woman
yeah didn't get a refund in a shop
that's owned by a South Asian guy she
basically tried to steal something he
took it off
she started hitting him he fell back and
now this guy's in hiding yeah because
he's part of the white supremacist the
South Asian guy he's a white supremacist
yes and you're just going what are any
of you talking about yeah it's
completely yeah it's ridiculous but I
think that also illustrates why terms
like Bame b-a-m-e
um is not you really useful because it
assumes that the experiences and the
values of all ethnic minority people in
the UK are the same when it's obviously
not the case
um Asian people can be prejudiced
against black people black people can be
prejudiced against Asian people and to
just assume that any kind of
sort of conflicts between these groups
is a consequence of white supremacy is
extremely condescending to these groups
as well yeah and it's also it's just
deeply weird it
deeply weird because
you could these people and you just
think to themselves
I what are you talking about it doesn't
make sense when you look at where this
happened is it happened in Peckham and
then for those people who've never been
to Peckham there's no ago right okay but
there's not a lot of white people there
if you're gonna look forward but not for
that reason yeah
exactly but you just go you are not
gonna find a lot of white supremacy in
Peckham well actually there are there
are some white people but it's it's a
certain kind of white people yes it's
being gentrified so it's a sort of
liberal youngish Progressive type it's
not it's not the kind of white people
you normally associate with white
supremacy yeah um yeah
and this is it and and I think this is
really what we're talking about where
what is the people are living in a a
fictional world they're living in a
world that they literally go that they
go online and they're being told that
this world exists yes and then they're
living in this world and you go but
that is not reality in any shape or form
yes and no one's denying racism exists
of course it doesn't there are racist
people
but that is not the experience
of living in Peckham yeah exactly and I
think that's one of the things that I
try to get across in my writings is that
all too often when you talk about race
and
um discrimination it's done with
um it's done through a very abstract
perspective it's done with a lot of
theory a lot of buzzwords without any
reference to the actual
um to use a fashionable term lived
experiences of of ethnic minorities
people and also white British people as
well
um because their experiences can't
simply be reduced to being victims of
racism
um and in fact that kind of perspective
to Simply say that as a black person as
an Asian person your experiences of
living in the UK can be explained
entirely through racism that's that's a
completely
um I think that's a profoundly damaging
Distortion of their actual experiences
actual complex experiences and I think
that also denigrates their Humanity as
well to Simply consider them as purely
victims of racism rather than as complex
fully embodied people because because
there are instances where you go I'll so
take Windrush for example of course yes
I'm not I don't know how much of that is
racist but you could but it's pretty
obvious that these people these these
immigrants at the time and British
citizens were horrendously badly treated
yeah of course let's talk about that
let's talk about how we can ensure that
doesn't happen yes yes yeah and I think
when wash is a is an excellent example
because when Russia is something which
is very much specific to a UK context
you can't really translate the
experience of wendrash to say America
for example because you can't really
call Black Americans an immigrant
Community because
um the vast majority of black Americans
are descendants from descendants of
enslaved Africans they were transported
to America between the 17th and the 19th
centuries in fact the average black
American can trace their ancestry
further back than the average white
American
um because of course
um a lot most white Americans are
descendants
um not only from like these sort of
English uh founders of America but also
like successive waves of European
immigration
um from the middle of the 19th century
onwards
um so you can't really so you can you
can you can make the argument that black
Americans are almost like an indigenous
Community to America but you can't say
the same with black British people
um because
um the most the vast majority of black
British people are immigrants or the
children children with immigrants not
even from the Caribbean because
um 25 years ago the vast majority of
black British people were black
Caribbean people but over the past 25
years there's been a massive influx of
immigration from Africa which means that
the majority of black British people so
they are black Africans in fact there
are twice as many black African people
as there are black Caribbean people but
this isn't really incorporated into
discussions of race and racism enough no
absolutely and I was going to ask you
about uh you split your book into two
sections really you say this is America
and you talk about what America exactly
and then most of the book is about this
is Britain yeah so what are some of the
big differences now one of them you've
just pointed out which is the majority
of black people in this country today
are actually not the descendants of
slaves yeah that's true uh whereas in
America it's obviously the other way
around yeah uh what else is different uh
I think another key difference is that
in the UK we don't have that particular
history of
institutionalized segregation that
America obviously has
um so in the UK for example interracial
marriage has never been banned
um and in the UK
um black people and Asian people have
never been barred from Frozen
um so that particular historical Legacy
in America simply doesn't apply in the
UK context
um I think another key difference is
that in the UK
um there are many
um that there is there is much more
internal diversity within the black
British population than there is
um in America I would argue um so in the
UK
um you've got black Caribbean people
um black West African people black East
African people and various other black
communities so even to use a term like
black British is to
um we need to acknowledge that there is
diversity within that term so in terms
of education for example the experiences
of black Caribbean people
um are very different to the experiences
of black African people and from what I
hear you know particularly at school
those two groups of kids may not get on
that well and it's not because of white
supremacy yeah yeah yeah so in fact um
it's changed now but when I was growing
up
um
black Africans
um recent immigrants in particular were
often looked down upon
um there was a term at school when I was
growing up called freshy to be called
Fresh which means fresh off the boat
right
um
it is cool now it is cool now and I
think that's because of like things like
um afrobeats which is a kind of popular
West African music but when I was
growing up which wasn't too long ago
um to be called Fresh or freshy was used
as an insult often directed uh
black African immigrants or or recent or
like black African like people in
general
um but but I I and I think one of the
other key differences is that in terms
of something like exclusion
um black Caribbean pupils are more than
twice as likely to be excluded from
schools as black African people
um black African people also have
um better GCSE grades better a-level
grades
um and I think not acknowledging these
differences
um it's very important because if we
genuinely care about the social
inequalities
um in our society
um we need to recognize these specific
differences rather than making
generalizations based on race
um and I think I should also emphasize
that when I say black Caribbean pupils
I'm specifically referring to Black
Caribbean boys
so black Caribbean Girls tend to do much
better in terms of Education the black
Caribbean boys
um but I should also
um acknowledge the fact that the ethnic
minority
group that does at least well in
education
um other Roma traveler Gypsy communities
they tend to do at least well and
they're often sort of seen as whites so
it shows that when we try to when we
when we think about inequalities in
education simply looking at it through
the lens of race is completely
inadequate
hey Francis do you want to protect your
privacy cool so I do now that I'm an
International Celebrity who's appeared
on hit shows like The Joe Rogan
Experience I have to protect myself from
vicious people looking to tear me down
on the Michael Jackson of the internet
not the celebrity I would have gone for
but trust is important when picking a
VPN I don't trust anyone after she left
me she took everything Francis remember
what your lawyer said good point you can
trust expressvpn because they don't sell
your data to advertisers they've even
created software called trusted server
that means they can't store any data at
all expressvpn uses lightweight a VPN
protocol that makes user speeds faster
than ever expressvpn is now blazingly
fast you can watch HD videos with zero
buffering thousands of pounds in legal
fees the great thing about expressvpn is
that you don't need any technical skills
to set up just like Francis fire up the
app and it's one button to connect One
Tap on a button was all it needed for my
entire life to disintegrate
loads of people are saying that
expressvpn is the best VPN there is
Business Insider The Verge and many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn as
the number one VPN in the world go on
Francis protect yourself with
expressvpn use or link
expressvpn.com trigger today and get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's
expressvpn.com trigger visit
expressvpn.com trigger to learn more she
took everything
point I always remember when we were
talking about this with Tony Saul and in
preparation for the interview I read I
read his report and the education
section I found particularly fascinating
one of the highest achieving subgroups
in all of education is West African
girls they are crushing it yeah and this
is what frustrates me because all we do
is talk about the negatives why can't we
celebrate them yeah going yeah brilliant
why is it why can't we go that's amazing
or celebrate um British Chinese pupils
British Indian pupils they also do
extremely well in terms of Education as
well
um so this kind of pessimistic narrative
which with
mostly imported from America as simply
inconsistence with reality basically and
it's also the message that it's sending
out to these kids which is you're never
going to succeed you're never going to
you're never going to achieve anything
racism is everywhere yeah and then you
look at the actual stats and
it doesn't bear any relation yeah the
truth of course of course yeah that kind
of
um paralyzed in fatalism
um exactly it's not good for the the
kind of the self-confidence that we need
to inculcate and
um
whether black or Asian kids
um because
um if you tell people enough times that
they are the victims of racism they are
the victims of Oppression they are the
victims of discrimination
they will inevitably see it everywhere
that kind of self-reinforcing mechanism
they will completely imbibe it
um and they would be unable to actually
acknowledge the fact that no this is not
the case
um of course there's still racism in the
UK but to define the experiences of
black or Asian people entirely through
the perspective of of racism or race as
completely
um is completely inimical to what we
should try to
um imbiben them which is the truth
basically and I think I think that that
is one of the key aspects of my writing
I'm concerned with what is actually
going on whether something is actually
true or not well that's the most
important thing because that then allows
you if you're talking about policy or
whatever to make the right decisions yes
but I was curious at the individual
level do you think that this
um very simplistic victimhood driven
worldview do you think that is landing
with people you know you're in your sort
of mid to late 20s your generation and
younger do you feel that people young
people from ethnic minority backgrounds
are being persuaded to see themselves in
this way are being persuaded to think
that you know that life here is terrible
isn't it do you think they are I think
it's a mixed bag so I think amongst
um some young ethic minority people they
do definitely
imbibe that kind of message
um and the ones that do sort of imbibe
that kind of message are the ones that
are often invited onto TV shows and
invited on to write um newspaper columns
and magazine articles the ones that
don't really imbibe that kind of message
um just get on with their lives
basically they're not really political
in that sense they just get on with
their lives and just go and get a
banking job yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but I think I think it's great that
you're here because I do think it's
really important
um that people who don't imbibe that
narrative don't just go and get a job
yeah you know what I mean because they
need to speak yeah you know of course
and it's good to have you you're
speaking about it but I'm curious you
mentioned the disparities between
different groups sure and this is the
question that when it comes down to this
issue no one really wants to dig into
honestly yeah
why do different groups perform
differently if if let's say West African
girls are doing the best in education we
can conclude from that that whatever
whatever role places racism plays and
people's outcomes yeah it's not
inhibiting them yeah as much as it's
inhibiting someone else so why would
that be for why would Caribbean boys be
getting excluded at a rate that's crazy
yeah compared to everybody else and no
one wants to talk about things like
culture and all sorts yeah
so what class as well in class yeah so
tell us about that what are the
differences yeah yeah so it's all of
those things it's
um family structure it's
um culture it's class
um so many West African
um immigrant communities they most of
them came as I said earlier
um over the past 25 30 years
um and they've arrived from Independence
African countries
um so with the when was generation a lot
of them arrived from Caribbean colonies
so they were basically going to the
motherland essentially whereas with
recent African immigrant communities
they've arrived from independent African
countries and many of them were already
University educated in Africa
um so when they've when they when
they've arrived in the UK there is that
particular expectation that they want
their kids to be University at least
University educated as well so there is
that attitude of emphasizing the
importance of education
education is absolutely critical to the
way that many of these West African
families conceive of themselves edge
things like education things like
religion
things like a strong family Network all
of them absolutely critical and I think
that's part of the reason why for
example many West African families that
live in southeast London are absolutely
desperate to get their kids to be sent
to the grammar schools in Kent
because if you if you go to any Grammar
School in Kent one of the Striking
things is the number of West African
kids in these grammar schools and I
think that's because of that particular
culture of educational aspiration yeah
and look and we all know this but why is
it that we can't talk about it why can't
we have a simple Frank and honest
conversation because race might play a
factor but it's certainly not the whole
not all of the equation yeah because I
think when we when anyone makes this
point
um
people would counter by saying well
you're sort of victim blaming you're
saying oh this is the fault of black
Caribbean people this is the fault of
black Caribbean culture and people also
say oh you're denying the existence of
racism when in fact what I'm saying and
what many people are saying is that of
course racism might be a factor and of
course racism still exists in the UK
what we're arguing is that we should not
look at racism that's the only Factor we
should consider other things because it
simply doesn't make sense to think that
race is the only thing that shapes
things like educational outcomes because
if it did we would not be able to
explain the differences between various
black groups Tom he is a particularly
unpleasant question but it needs to be
us if your kid gets expelled isn't it
your fault well you mean the thought of
the Paris
all the children in the country they're
getting expelled isn't that because you
were you you didn't tutor them probably
yeah but as someone who taught for many
years you know it takes a lot for a kid
to get expelled very increasingly so
yeah and you something has gone wrong
yeah and somebody needs to take the
blame for it yeah yeah in the visual
agency yeah that does matter but I but I
think that we should also
um look at wider problems why why does
social so if you've say you're a young
kid and you grew up without any sort of
Father Figure and you grew up in in a
place where there is mass poverty in a
place where the only role models in your
Society are basically
um criminals or like like people that
are evolved in gang communities if you
go up within that particular environment
um
it would take a lot of individual
willpower to be studious to be
um focused on trying to better
yourselves
um so I think we should not
underestimate the extent to which peer
pressure plays a role because peer
pressure is one of the most powerful
social forces and it doesn't just apply
to this situation and applies to many
other situations
um so even though I do acknowledge that
individual agency is important I think
we should also consider other wider
social factors as well absolutely I mean
environment is so important but
one of our previous Studios was in East
London and it was like an oasis it was a
nice building yeah in the middle of a
big Council estate sure like a project
in America the project and I remember
Francis and I June this is during covert
would like go out for a walk and the
just the environment itself was so
depressing I was like if I lived here to
be a different person yeah yeah you know
what I mean so environment makes a big
difference in your point about father
figures and all of that is is really
true as well yeah I think yeah
um absolutely man the environment is
huge yes yeah yeah and I think that that
is something that
we need to acknowledge which is that the
environment of
black people or ethnic minority people
in general are not all the same and it's
a bit weird to sort of consider them to
be the same because the environments of
white people
isn't the same as well so why should we
assume that the environment of ethnic
minority people would be the same isn't
it a bit racist
to go pure black therefore you were
going to behave exactly like this have
these opinions yeah yeah and probably be
expelled from school I'm always
reluctant to to describe something as
racist yeah it has definitely
patronizing that is it is definitely
um counterproductive especially if you
consider yourself to be an avowed
anti-racist to make generalizations
based on race in that way I think it
shows
um an extreme lack of curiosity on your
part to not wonder the differences
whether that be cultural socioeconomic
um differences in terms of religion for
example between these various
um racial or ethnic groups
yeah I was going to say you alluded to
this earlier about which black voices
this is a very popular phrase of course
yes which
of black voices get promoted yeah in the
media yeah and as you probably know I've
had my classes with some of these people
yes uh on TV and stuff and it always
seems to be
the crazier the more the more Strider
the more strident is perhaps the kind of
way to describe it uh the people who who
are really very very extreme about what
they believe and I just wonder whether
they're representative of the average
black person because uh that's not been
my experience yeah and and I don't you
know what the media brainwashing is so
powerful
uh we get so many black people coming up
to us saying how much they enjoy the
show and obviously this has been part of
the message of the show that you you
know being a victim is not good for you
and all of that and even I knowing that
every now and again I'm I'm a little bit
surprised I'm like oh wow black person
likes us do you know what I mean yeah
yeah because I know I know that this
thing is so powerful in our minds yeah
exactly yeah um and I just I wonder if
you agree with me that I well or you
forget about agree with me I wonder how
representative you think the media
conversation is to what ordinary black
and brown and whatever people are sort
of talking around the dinner table it's
not representative at all would be my
answer to that yeah because I I think
the actual experiences of black people
um
are so diverse that to even use
um a term like
black Voice or the black community
does a massive disservice to those
different values those different points
of views those different experiences
so I I think and the kind the kinds of
things as well that black people often
discuss the kind of values that black
people often espouse are often counter
to the kind of values that many of these
um self-appointed
um black pundits or intellectuals or
whatever you want to call them what what
they express because I think one of the
things about
um many black people in the UK um I'm
thinking in particular of many black
African communities is the extent to
which religion plays a pivotal role in
how they see themselves
um and the kind of cultural or social
conservatism which is implied by that is
not something that we often discuss well
they don't have pride Flags
yeah it's not something that
um is often um discussed because that
would lead to many awkward conversations
and I think it's one thing I want to
emphasize is that London is the most
religious place in the UK and London
yeah and by the way acceptance of LGBT
it's the most conservative yeah the most
conservative in that respect yeah and
it's it's because of yeah ethnic
minorities or religious differences yeah
exactly exactly yeah and it's not just
um it's not just like the black or or
even or Asian Muslim it's also like
um Eastern European immigrants as well
who often tend to be quite Catholic as
well yeah in terms of the religious
background
um so that's that's why
um there is that kind of tension which
is that in in the most
Multicultural parts of the country you
also get the most
um religious
um sensibilities which are expressed
and yet at the same time they uh the the
white middle class liberal expects all
of these people to vote labor yeah and
to have deeply Progressive views but
they do though this is the question I
was going to ask you yeah why do big
cities then and it's it's not just
London obviously but why do all the big
cities and you see it here and in
America that's one of the uniting
factors is they're always consistently
left-wing yeah right yeah which is
interesting given what you're saying
right how do you explain that yeah I
think I think
um
I think it's it's it's it's just a kind
of political tribalism essentially
rather than any sorts of genuine
consideration of the policies
um and the values that are embodied by
any particular party
um so I think with voted preferences
it's it's often based on Vibes it's
often based on any sort of
um pre-intellectual affiliation rather
than any genuine consideration of of any
sort of of what the parties actually
stand for do you think part of it is
also as well that
you know
if you come from an ethnic minority that
automatically means that you are in the
minority yeah yeah and therefore you
were going to you do not want to stand
out as much because you don't want to be
alienated from your tribe whatever your
tribe may be by being conservative or
saying hey guys I think this commentator
is actually talking nonsense I think
that is a part of it
um but I also think there's another
striking Dimension to discussions about
diversity and politics
um so one of the interesting things
about the UK is that in the conservative
party we there are many
um prominent conservative politicians
that come from an Asian background
including our current prime minister uh
Mr Rishi sunak
um but I think one dimension to this
hasn't been spoken enough about which is
that many of these
um prominent Asian conservative
politicians
um
didn't arrive directly from Asia they
came through the roots of East Africa
um and I think
um and I think it makes sense why the
families
espouse conservative points of views
because
um if if you come from
um if your family comes from an East
African country where they were
basically kicked out by the girl like
the Jews of Easter yeah they're
basically kicked out because they were
considered parasites
um if you come from that particular
background it would make sense why you
would not trust the government to solve
all the issues in society it would make
sense why you wouldn't trust the states
it would make sense why you would
emphasize the importance of family the
importance of individuals driving
individual aspiration if you come from
that particular background
um and I think it does make sense why
people like we wish you see that and the
other prominent conservative Asian
politicians are are conservative because
of that particular
um background and I think it also makes
sense why somebody like um Cami
Butternut
who's also a very prominent
conservative politician from a West
African background because even though
she was born in the UK she actually grew
up in Nigeria and when she was growing
up in Nigeria Nigeria was a military
dictatorship
so it would make sense why she's got
many positive views about the UK
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver Turner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
it's really interesting that you bring
up people like Cami and conservative
politicians yes and
the thing that I have
I am I'm very troubling about the way f
etty people in particular a certain
subsection of ethnic minority people
discuss these these figures yeah is that
they are a traitor to their race yeah
and that to me just seems It's racist
yes
that is racist that is definitely racist
and it's something that
um some people have leveled against me
as well
um so like anyone that deviates from
that particular
Orthodoxy is viewed as a traitor
um and is
um demonized in that way just because
they disagree with the view that racism
doesn't explain everything in society
um it's completely absurd well I'll see
you and I'll raise you a controversial
issue because something I talked about
in my book but I'd be curious to get
your take on it which is slavery and I
find the way that people in Britain talk
about slavery is just like it's I I I'm
just like what how are we talking about
in this way because
people everywhere throughout history had
slaves and practiced slavery now
admittedly the transatlantic slave trade
because the Brits were the most
technologically sophisticated nation in
the world they could transport slaves
across oceans Etc sure but broadly
speaking all big Empires always had
slaves and used them right yeah and the
British were the first people one of the
very first big Empires I think the first
Empire to end slavery and committed a
lot of blood and treasure and so on to
doing it
but we have this unique obsession with
it as some kind of like uniquely evil
thing that people in this country did
all colonialism more generally right and
you're going well yeah and it's
interesting because I went to the Museum
of slavery in Liverpool great museum
except they don't tell you who captured
the slaves maybe we should look into
that as well you know what I mean what
do you make of the way that we talk
about that issue yeah I find discussions
around slavery and colonialism extremely
reductive
um because
um as you rightly say Constantine
um slavery is
um a part of every historical
civilization and Society
um it makes sense why we would try to
understand
various aspects of slavery absolutely
and try to understand whether those
legacies
um still affect contemporary Society but
to focus almost exclusively on slavery
um
where for instance
there are twice as many Asian people in
the UK as there are black people
um and it's not clear to me
how the transatlantic slave trade for
example
um explains their own historical
experiences
um and in the case of colonialism of
course there are many there are many um
terrible things that the British did
um under the auspices of colonialism
um but to Simply view colonialism as
just
um just a succession of evil acts it's a
sort of view colonialism through the
perspective of domination I think is
also historically
um prevents you really that's
interesting because I I've never made
I've never taken an argument that far
okay but I guess it sounds like what
you're saying is colonialism
not not benefits well it was a complex
thing so for example an aspect of
colonialism
um which
um is a really
um acknowledged enough as the aspects of
the missionaries
um so the reason why
um for example many
um West African leaders
um became
anti-colonial in the first place was
because many of them were educated in
schools by missionaries
so in a paradoxical sense there are
certain aspects of colonialism that sort
of field the seeds that ended up
undermining colonism in the first place
um and these missionary schools were um
of course Christian
um and many of the kind of many of the
values that these
um postcolonial leaders imbibes in these
schools
um values such as opposition to
Injustice of any kind they came from
these missionary teachers
um so in a sense colonialism was
um paradoxical in in that sense I'm
talking about British colonialism
because of that which is not to on the
play or to underestimate the many evils
perpetrated by colonizing powers or
British colitis and powers in particular
it's just to say that there are nuances
and there are complexities within that
as well so you're saying we're the good
guys basically
but you know there was one I was
watching this program it's actually a
really good program one of the few good
programs the BBC does uh we're called
who do you think you are yes and there
was this beautiful really
unintentionally hilarious moment where
they got one of these celebrities uh I I
can't remember who it was black lady and
they were talking about her ancestor who
was a slave obviously she was very upset
by this understandably so yes and then
she went well this slave won her won his
freedom she was like oh marvelous that's
so good and then they went and then he
went on to own slaves and she was
absolutely mortified and it was to me it
was this
it was it was funny in a way because it
was like it's not simple yeah and this
idea that we're presented with yeah and
this
this how can I put it productive yeah
reductive view of History yeah of course
yeah and it's it's nonsensitive yeah
yeah and I and I think that kind of view
of history as well also explains why
there is this view that there is some
sort of universal black identity that
black people around the world all share
the same values and the same beliefs and
the same Outlook
um and this is completely wrong
um from my own particular experience as
well so as I said at the at the very
start um I was born in Nigeria
um and in Nigeria over 99 of the
population is black so you don't have
diversity
there's really no mental diversity is
their strength not racial diverse other
types of diversity so the um so of
course race is not at the Forefront of
the minds of the ordinary Nigerian
um and race is not one of the factors
that
um Divine Society
um other factors such as ethnic tribal
group religion
um region or geography those are the
things that shape the Visions within
Nigerian Society
um and and this this became
evident to me when um last year
um my brother was getting married and my
brother lives in America and he was
getting married to an African-American
woman so a woman was ancestors uh more
enslaved Africans and she brought along
um a lot of her family members and
friends to Nigeria and I and I assumed
that many of these black Americans
expected a kind of homecoming a kind of
Return of the prodigal son or daughter
or whatever
um but the Striking thing is that
what struck many of these Nigerians was
not the fact that these black Americans
who are black it was the fact that these
black Americans were Americans so the
americanness of them was the most
striking thing to the Nigerians
um which I think just goes to illustrate
that
race is not at the Forefront of the
minds of many African people themselves
other things might shape the way that
they look at Black Americans black
British people
um and black people from across the rest
of the world so what you're saying is
and it's very controversial is that
people's skin color doesn't determine
how they act and behave and think that's
I mean that's incredible man such a
radical voice it's a radical idea
radical idea listen it's it's a it's a
great book and it's great chatting to
you as we start to move towards the end
of the interview what would be your
message to young people growing up in
this country
um who have been you know they've had
this stuff shoved at them from every
social media and media and TV and
whatever
how should people think about
um you know being from a minority
background in this country you know oh
look everyone's got a different
experience yeah of course what are some
of the important things do you think
that people should take away when
they're being presented with as you talk
about in the book a very Americanized
downloaded from Hollywood sort of
narrative yeah what's a what's a helpful
way to think about you know race
relations in this country and so on
by going to the neighbors by speaking to
their friends by observing what's going
on in the local community
um their cities their towns
um The Wider country
um simply by looking at each individual
on their own terms rather than through
the perspective of their racial
background whatever that might be or
through any kind of assumption
based on race or ethnicity
um it's by acknowledging that each
person
is both rooted in their own particular
context their own particular
environments but also at the same time
each person is endowed with a certain
kind of indivisible moral dignity a
certain kind of universal
um moral dignity and they should be
looked at through that perspective as
well rather than any kind of abstract
ideas about what it means to be black
are you saying you should treat people
on the content of their characters
yeah it was weird yeah it is it's
outdated and frankly yeah
straight
[Laughter]
there will be somebody who thinks Martin
Luther King Jr is a race Trader no
absolutely yeah you know but look it's
been a one great the book is called this
is not America make sure to check it out
and the final question is not the final
question because we're going to go to
locals as we always do before we go to
locals what's one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
could it be on anything anything
anything
um I think one issue is um and it's
something I've been recently thinking
about is the um I think we should be
talking more about the negative impacts
of pornography on young men
um so one striking thing of noticist is
that
um many of my
um young male friends are being shown
adverts
um sort of advertising Viagra
uh which which yeah yeah yeah yeah and
this is something that
um because erectile dysfunction which is
something we associate with older men
there's been a recent massive Spike
amongst younger men
um pun intended
uh and um definitely and and I think
that
um I I don't know if if pornography is
definitely definitely the factor that's
inspiring influencing that but
um I think you might well be
um and I think this this is of course a
very awkward conversation to have
because it speaks to
um something that's very intimate but I
think it's I think I think for in the
future I think the
um negative deleterious effects of
online pornography is something that
will be a major social and policy
question very interesting well uh
appreciate you coming on the show uh
join us uh over on locals where we
continue the conversation with your
questions and we'll probably have a few
more of our own see you there
is it possible to discuss race without
also discussing class
[Music]
foreign